all right Chris let's answer some
questions Charleston South Carolina
James your question for Chris and me hey
Chris and Dave let me tell you guys I am
way better than I deserve to Jesus be
the glory and I have a feeling you're
both in the same boat yes sir yep anyway
so my question really is will backup
info I'm getting married this coming
December to the love of my life
um anyhow he actually may I'd say you're
marrying up here but she has done an
amazing job in her life with handling
money I'm just starting on thankfully on
debt-free arm I'm actually in baby step
3 right now and I'm trying to hit a
$10,000 goal by this coming May so in
about five months and I'm right now I'm
at five thousand however she has just
let me know that she actually has
already in her possession a fully funded
emergency fund for when we do get
married and so my question is would it
be okay under these circumstances to
kind of cheat baby step three to baby
step four I would ask you like to start
a Roth IRA probably around March
assuming everything still goes okay I'll
still keep putting money away towards
what will be an emergency fund then
it'll turn into some other funds
probably a car fund when we get married
um just under the pretense that the
fully funded emergency fund will come
from her once we do get married Chris
hey James I think you know this I see
the logic I see that your way of
thinking when you think about your
financial legacy it's going to be a lot
longer than one year it's gonna be a lot
longer than really we're talking about
is from May into December and it's going
to be a bigger deal than that and so for
me I say you you don't want to do this
there's a lot of things that can happen
in life
between now and December and for me I
wouldn't do that
I wouldn't I would stick with the plan
and then once you guys are all you've
combined your finances and you've
accomplished baby step three then you
can start talking about the investing
but I wouldn't do that my friend and
here's another reason I completely agree
with Chris there's no other reason you
you said to us she's really good with
handling money and you kind of said
you're not didn't you have that okay so
what what this is what this is is
exercise you're going to learn to build
your saving muscle as a part of
preparing to marry this woman that is
beyond your reach
all right so it's going to make you a
better husband just to build your saving
muscle all year and you know when you're
in life transition like getting married
combining households maybe even changing
cities or jobs those kinds of things is
when you need extra cash laying around
you really can't have too much cash now
if you're sitting there and everything's
completely stabilized and you're sitting
on too much cash then yeah invest some
of that without a doubt you're going to
do that but this cash this is what
financial will be called liquidity
meaning you've just got this pile of
cash it's just oil in the gears man plus
it's a good exercise for you and it
won't hurt you Chris is exactly right
take a longer-term view and it makes the
answer become very very apparent you
know why most people don't win they
don't bother you have to bother it to be
intentional never again as American
Express is going to call my house and
ask my wife why she would stay with a
man that won't pay his bills